j'ai eu envie de vous faire découvrir la
vie des locataires d'un immeuble
parisien en plein cœur de la capitale à
la Bastille ah oui j'ai oublié de vous
dire que c'est aussi là qu'habite René
une vieille dame devenue actrice de
cinéma à l'âge de 74 ans
de me suivre toi aussi gros tu restes la
personne bouge c'est pas l'heure pour ça
il y a des heures
moi aussi il reste là-bas aussi
on viendra pas me voler en tout cas
allez
ben oui
bien gros
tu veux venir viens gros
allez viens
[Musique]
c'est toujours mes jambes
dans tes bras là alors j'y vais
tranquille tu vois j'y vais toujours
ah bah ça y est bonjour
les marchands à peu près une nuit non
c'est pas mauvais
prenez vous habitez dans cette immeuble
depuis combien de temps c'est bien en
vous êtes la plus ancienne ici une des
plus anciennes il y a une domicile plus
vieille que moi la 87 ans je crois vous
connaissez tout le monde à peu près
surtout que j'ai fait la concierge un
moment ici dans cette loge là pendant 9
mois parce qu'on avait personne le temps
de trouver quelqu'un alors en dehors de
mon travail je venais donner le courrier
et puis un coup de balai quand même en
plus de votre travail
on se met un peu à tout ce qui est pas
mal d'ailleurs après j'ai fini le
restaurant
je vais prendre un grade
je faisais rien on est les téléphones ça
m'allait mieux j'avais vieilli je
travaillais jusqu'à 73 ans jusqu'à 73
ans
il a demandé 50 ans maintenant
alors il y a maintenant à peu près deux
ans vous êtes devenu la vedette du gars
La Valette du quartier en tournant dans
le film de Cédric lapiche chacun cherche
son chat
très bien très sympathique les gens
aussi je t'amusant parce que les gens me
reconnaissent on me connaissait déjà
avant tandis que maintenant je servais à
bonjour madame en ligne bonjour monsieur
bonjour madame bonjour madame j'ai pas
qui c'est ça vous fait plaisir d'être
reconnu comme ami
ça m'a fait voyager surtout que ça m'a
entraîné loin là au mois de juillet je
suis moi les trois fois
à La Rochelle et à Nantes pour la sortie
du film dans des petits pays
alors ça c'est pas désagréable parce
qu'ils me prennent ma porte et ils me
ramène
c'était la première fois qu'on voyait ah
oui je voyageais
c'est quoi le bricolage
mais je ne me gênais pas parti parce que
comme j'avais mes animaux j'aimais pas
les conflits j'en ai jamais tout seul
avec un animal
ça oblige à sortir ça oblige à parler ça
mon 18e chien vous n'avez jamais été
marié
mon fils puisque j'ai un fils mais
jamais de mariage non pourquoi parce que
vous étiez au style mariage ou c'est pas
cher
j'avais l'habitude de vivre comme ça
même encore maintenant ou c'est je
j'aime bien l'idée de prendre quelqu'un
pour attendre pour être la patience pour
y croire
vous préférez la vie la vie du quartier
ça dépend
enfin ça fait un peu notre port
d'attache on a des nouvelles de tout le
monde des uns des autres dans la maison
ici c'est la maison
c'est comme une maison c'est la maison
vous y êtes attaché ah oui oui j'irai
pas ailleurs donc je pourrais monter mon
cinquième deux ou trois fois par jour
malheureusement je serai peut-être
obligé d'en partir d'une façon ou d'une
autre
pour l'instant je préfère rester comme
ça vous avez vu des gens qui étaient cet
immeuble qui était qui était proche de
vous qui était proche de moi bah oui il
y a eu des divorce il y a eu des décès
aussi dans mon escalier je les compte à
12 le déc
j'ai enterré l'homme et la femme
aussi longtemps de temps quand je suis
rentré ici d'ailleurs j'étais là jeune
parmi les vieilles c'était moi la plus
jeune la dame ici la dame derrière là ça
part avant moi après sera mon tour mais
j'attends ça que vous dites merde
qu'est-ce que vous aimez ici et ben
j'aime tout ce qui est ancien comme
comme est-ce qu'il y a maintenant puis
vous c'est mon habitué aux gens on se
croit en sécurité on se croissant qui
j'aurais quelque chose je sais où elle
est taper mais vous les connaissez donc
à Valentin
vous vous croisez simplement vos voisins
je crois on a un petit restaurant à côté
là où on se réunit on se réunit dans ce
petit café là c'est un peu notre club
c'est rassurant de connaître justement
toute la vie
oui c'est rassurant qu'il faut des
années pour connaître quelqu'un toute la
jeunesse qui rentre ils sont très très
gentils mais il faut longtemps pour les
connaître et puis je sais pas du tout
les mêmes choses on est on est moins
rapproché que quand on est exactement du
même âge il y a des jeunes dans mon
escalier vous avez bien vu vous parlez
avec eux à l'occasion bien sûr vous
aimez bien la compagnie des jeunes
j'adore les jeunes je regrette de pas
être né à la même époque quoi
je trouve qu'ils vivent qui font
beaucoup de bruit ça m'aurait été moi ça
puisqu'il y a maintenant c'est modernisé
c'est-à-dire qu'on nous a mis les
sanitaires à l'intérieur tandis qu'avant
les avait dehors c'est pas que c'était
mal ça nous permettait de nous voir
quand on voulait voir quelqu'un on
entendait la porte tiens une sortie on
dérangeait personne et on avait des
nouvelles comme ça tandis que là
beaucoup moins maintenant vous n'êtes
jamais agacé par personne ici
un peu tard vous faites la police dans
la cour ou à l'extérieur gris par la
fenêtre qu'est-ce que vous dites et vous
fermez c'est l'heure
vous êtes du genre à rouspéter René
j'étais à pousser des vraiment des on me
dit que je suis plutôt les rentrent
maintenant
en général on crie davantage on apprend
tout et puis c'est quand on sait tout
qu'on s'envole et après faudrait faire
une double vie on la gérer beaucoup
mieux surtout moi
un moelleux on la gère beaucoup mieux on
devrait vivre deux fois bonjour madame
bonjour ça va madame
ça va ça va ça va
oui depuis 58 ans
je suis venu là pour ma ligne de miel
j'y suis restée depuis 1939 voilà on
déménageait
j'ai une fille
qu'elle habite de nos escaliers
vous allez faire vos courses
il y a tellement longtemps qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé là
mieux pas en parler
s'il s'en souvient aussi ah quand ils
sont venus
ou c'est pas ça c'était
mauvais caractère de temps en temps elle
dit des trucs comme ça qui fait que je
me rappelle franchement
je m'en souviens
avec mon mari et moi il y a pas de
concierge c'est pour concierge à
l'époque c'était moi non non
de votre passage de comme concierge vous
avez combien d'années ça cette histoire
vous êtes en froid depuis 16 ans
mon escalier c'est plus facile on se
rend compte plus facilement quand même
vous dites bonjour d'habitude jamais
alors pourquoi vous êtes venus lui dire
bonjour là pour vous
enfin familier quoi
j'étais plutôt on dirait réservé quoi
comme je connaissais pas le monde mais
je fais un effort maintenant je parle
oui vous êtes venus
mais mon petit-fils
me vois si je passe à la télé je sais
pas si je passe ou pas
il y a une caméra qui est là
regardez il y en a plein autour de vous
quand même
c'est pour l'automne ça passe à
l'automne au début
la vie à l'endroit
[Musique]
allez au revoir au revoir
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]